[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday august 9th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
crypto has been one of the hottest
technologies for the past several years
luring countless entrepreneurs billions
in funding from investors and an
impassioned base of crypto holders
one of the people who saw an opportunity
in the space was alex mashinsky who
founded the crypto lender celsius in
2017.
a serial entrepreneur mashinsky has been
barreling into industries promising to
revolutionize them for nearly 30 years
in an interview with high tech tv at a
crypto conference in 2018 machinski said
his goal was to get more people into
crypto
celsius succeeded in getting a lot of
people on board promising depositors
high returns and low risk
but the company held onto little
collateral to back up its loans
according to 2021 investor documents
reviewed by the wall street journal
and in june amid a drop in crypto values
it froze customer accounts and last
month it filed for bankruptcy protection
this isn't the first of mashinsky's
projects to leave a sour taste for
partners and investors
so how did mushinsky get to this point
and what happens to celsius's customers
joining us to discuss this is wsj
reporter vicky huang hi vicki thanks for
joining me thank you for having me
so alex mashinsky he was a big name in
the crypto market so was his company
celsius can you tell us a bit about how
he rose to prominence in this space yes
so
alex mashinsky launched celsius network
in 2017
and just within five years he grew it
into one of the biggest crypto lenders
in the space
the company
had more than
20 billion assets at its peak
so alex is frequently on youtube live
streaming answering questions of celsius
customers he has always been a regular
fixture at different crypto conferences
and
media
so
he really was sort of the
face of the company you know so many uh
tech founders and particularly crypto
founders they have this kind of this
cachet this like aura about them that
really attracts
certain investors and groups of people
did machinski have that was that true
for him in celsius
yes
he often spoke about celsius in very
grand terms
he often spoke about leaving a legacy
for his kids that's why he's building
this company and
he often spoke about building a
decentralized financial platform so he
definitely has that sort of draw for
investors and customers he definitely
built a legion of loyal customers who
he calls celsius
and
he was able to draw
a lot of institutional investors as well
last year celsius raised 750 million
dollars from some very credible
institutional investors
okay but now you know the crypto market
is going through this this route people
are pulling their money out and celsius
in particular has filed for bankruptcy
what has the company or mashinsky said
about the company going through this
process
so alex machinski has been fairly quiet
about things since the company paused
withdrawals in june and it hasn't really
made any comments in media or responded
to any of our requests for comment
but in a statement issued after celsius
filed for bankruptcy in july mr
machinski did say the move was the right
decision for community and company
he said i'm confident when we look back
at the history of celsius we'll see this
as a defining moment
but we should know here that companies
can restructure
and emerge from the bankruptcy court
okay you know this is not mshinsky's
first venture he had a lot of experience
before doing this can you tell us a
little bit about that what was his
background
he
is a serial entrepreneur
who
really proposed a lot of different
moonshot ideas in different industries
over many years
so he
promised revolutions in long-distance
calling airport rides before getting
into crypto
but really
some of his companies have been more
successful than others
but he often left companies under very
intense circumstances
one of these companies ground link which
we looked into
it basically had the same idea as uber
or lyft today but the company for some
reason didn't really take off
and then a private equity company took
over and installed new leadership so
alex exited the company
you know given that experience what are
people who you spoke to kind of saying
about what's happened at celsius how are
they kind of linking those two things
some business associates who worked with
alex in the past they are not exactly
surprised about how celsius ended up in
today's state given how they interacted
with alex and how he often had these big
ideas and
wanted to grow at all costs but i
couldn't really see it through
you know for the investors and customers
who bought into the idea of celsius
where are they going to be left now and
is there anything we can learn from the
past ventures that would kind of help us
get some foresight on what their
situation might end up being
for many investors and customers and
celsius it's
likely to be a long uphill battle for
them in terms of getting their money
back
because terms of use on the celsius
website state that in the event of a
bankruptcy customers might not be able
to recover the cryptocurrencies in their
accounts or
the collateral they put up to take out
loans from celsius so
it might take a long time for customers
to see
their money
back if they ever get to have their
money back
all right that's our reporter vikki
huang thanks so much for joining us
vicky thank you for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you